forget nootropics the single best way to
give yourself a cognitive upgrade is to
improve the quality and quantity of your
sleep and forget bodybuilding
supplements the single best way to
improve your gains and your strength is
to improve the quality and quantity of
your sleep
ah what they're a fine day for science
if you're serious about strength
training fitness losing weight or
improving the sharpness of your mind
then it's very important that you put a
big emphasis on the quality and quantity
of your sleep the more you sleep the
better you sleep the better your next
day's going to be you'll be able to
retain information better you'll be in a
better mood you'll have more energy also
during sleep is when the body builds
muscle and repairs from the damage you
put it through in the gym so when your
body's most anabolic as opposed to
catabolic meaning you're building
tissues that are burning it and it also
has long-term effects if you keep
getting good night's sleep and it lays
with your plasticity you'll learn things
faster and your body always being
generally much better shape if you're
interested in self-improvement and
fitness etc as I am you'll probably have
found that there are countless different
ideas and tips and hacks on how you can
improve your sleep these involve
everything from relying on a spiky mat
to taking zma supplements to using
valerian root and if you can get these
massive lists of all these different
sleep packs and you can go through them
all and try and do everything perfectly
to get the best sleep you can
unfortunately most of them either don't
work or they're negligible is and
they're just not worth the effort
instead of a there's barely anything
spiky sleep matters ridiculous etc and
all of them are just impractical as well
so I'm more interested in looking at a
few simple things you can do they'll
have big impacts you know you're not
going to find a magic bullet some of
these aren't that easy to implement but
they're the simple straightforward truth
for enhancing sleep so the first and
most important tip and the obvious place
to start is just try and get more sleep
as in prioritizing give it the respect
it deserves if you are serious like say
about improving your strength and your
cognitive abilities then you need to
prioritize sleep you need to get your
eight hours if possible six will do if
you have to and you need to make sure
that you create a quiet environment to
sleep in you know if you're staying up
all night till 2:00 a.m. in the morning
watching YouTube videos then it's no
surprise if you're functioning and
eating Villette
rude isn't gonna help you next up is try
having a hot shower or hot bath before
you go to bed
this has loads of good benefits improves
your body temperature it relaxes the
muscles far more effectively than many
of these relaxants you can take it just
puts you in a relaxing mood and I
believe it helps to stimulate the
production of growth hormone which will
make your sleep even more anabolic this
is the example this is an example of a
simple straightforward thing that really
does make a big difference just take a
nice hot bath before bed and then go to
sleep and I think you'll notice the
difference plus you can stay in bed a
little bit longer the next day because
you have to shower or bath for the next
morning so that's one of the major
things I recommend you do obviously not
all these things are always going to be
practical or convenient and maybe you
don't like showering in the evening and
you'd rather do it in the morning that's
fine you know this is just my ideas just
take a couple of them then hopefully
they'll be useful another really
important thing to do is to just take
half an hour or 15 minutes to unwind and
relax in the evening great to do this
it's just with a book in bed like an old
person this is a great way to let your
mind unwind if you're stressed it's a
great way to chill out at the same time
you can feel your eyes don't tire out
from the focusing which makes you feel
sleepy and it gives you a break from
screens like your phone and your
computer see I experimented for a while
with blue blocking shades I was gonna
wear them for you but I can't find them
but I'm sure you'll get over that these
are kind of yellow looking shades that
block out the blue spectrum of the light
see the problem with mobile phones and
computers is that the blue light that
they produce it makes your brain
mistakes it for sunlight and that
produces more cortisol instead of
melatonin so you kind of wake up in the
old days we didn't have TVs and even
when we were using candlelight that
wouldn't be enough to wake us up but
these days we kind of always Wyatt
always staring at screens which is also
stressful because you're getting emails
from people all the time that might be
stressing you out and then you're
supposed to just go straight to sleep
while still kind of Wired out so the
idea of reblocking shades was to block
the light that comes from the screens
and also you can get other devices and
other ways of doing this like apps that
block the blue
spectrum on your mobile phone problem
with blue blocking shades is that I wore
them for a couple of evenings and my
wife was like why is such a prick you
know because you look like a knob it's
not very convenient you bump into stuff
because it's dark and yeah and then
other people say well you know install
the app on your phone then suddenly the
TV's on that undoes it so just take 15
minutes out at the end of the day to do
some readings sit quietly to chill out
and I'll make a massive difference to
your benefit then go immediately to
sleep and have a much more restful sleep
we are a snow sky-high the next one is
to keep a window open or just to keep
the temperature in your room a little
cooler whilst you sleep this makes a big
difference because that's how we used to
sleeping that's how we evolved to sleep
obviously our environments was cooler
and your body can regulate its
temperature a little better that way you
can still give yourself enough duvet and
cover to climb under to stay warm but
rather than creating a toasty atmosphere
to sleep in and try and create a
slightly cooler atmosphere to sleep in
and after that nice warm bath you should
feel all snuggly and yeah your sleep way
better again it's simple it's easy it's
obvious even but it works finally as far
as quick and simple tricks go or tips
just make sure that you're getting
plenty of exercise during the day before
you go to bed and especially running and
walking outdoors that's especially good
because then you're getting fresh air
you're getting sunlight and vitamin D
and of course you're tiring your body
out a little bit more and then you'll be
you'll find it much easier to sleep when
you go to bed that night so so far so
dull you might be thinking none of this
stuff is exactly groundbreaking that's
kind of the point but one gadget that I
do think is awesome for improving not so
much your sleep but your ability to wake
up in the morning and prevent sleep
inertia that's that nasty groggy feeling
that you get is this it's a new me and I
think mine was called the loony starter
10 or stars 50 or something but there's
lots of different models there you go
Kamehameha point is this device is a
lamp it's called a daylight
lamp or daylight clock and the idea is
that it creates light that is a similar
wavelength to the Sun so it does exactly
the same thing as your mobile phones in
your screens but except this time you're
doing it on purpose
and it happens in the morning which is
when you want to wake up and happen
slowly so what you can do is you can set
it set the alarm so say you want to wake
up at 9:00 which is quite nice late
morning for you jealous then what you
can do is you set the alarm and then
starting at 8:40 or whatever it
gradually stuff to get brighter like
like say it's a little smoother when it
does it but the idea is that it's
rousing you out to sleep and it's
actually very effective sometimes it
actually wakes me up because if once you
get to 9:00 and then beat and I think
the more expensive models you can get
all do things like make nice birdie
noises let me tell you a ghost story
the more expensive ones can make birdie
noises or more natural sounds to wake
you up but this one just beeps but the
point is if you're lucky and if it's
worked really well then you wake up
without even leaving the noise and when
that happens you feel that you've had
the longest night it's like such a
natural way to wake up so it's better
than being startled awake by a loud
buzzing noises honestly that's great but
even if you don't wake up by the light
alone and you do need the alarm just the
fact that your light is room and in a
very that your room is light and in a
very natural and kind of refreshing
light makes a massive difference you're
not waking up from the dark just like
instead you waking up in this really
nice bright space it makes a massive
difference and I recommend that gadget
that wasn't too expensive so there's a
little hack for you if you did want a
hack by the way just an additional note
the Lummi is very good if you start from
sad that seasonal affective disorder
this is a condition where you feel just
generally low and possibly even
depressed during the winter months
that's because it can help to improve
your body clock in general throughout
the day by giving yourself the externals
I think of a time giver that you need in
order to set your body clock in motion
so if you are someone who struggles to
get up in the morning and feels low all
day in the winter you might especially
benefit from something like this and as
well as helping you feel better in the
morning
using something like this to prevent
sleep inertia can also help you to wake
up more quickly which means you can get
more done this was something I really
struggled with when I first started
working for myself so if you can't find
ways to wake up quicker that's really
good and one more tip on in regards to
that which is something that a lot of
people would advise you don't do I
actually find it really useful in the
morning to grab my phone and check my
emails it one says don't do that because
then you're becoming reactive instead of
proactive and you're stressing yourself
out first thing in the morning
personally I find my emails that
stressful and I'm great to just ignoring
stuff that I don't care about so this
isn't a problem for me but I get paid by
my email and I like to browse Facebook
and I like to play games I'd like to see
how many views my websites had so this
is something actually we look forward to
doing in the morning and so when I wake
up and I'm too tired to just spring out
of bed well I'm not not what I'm
normally not too tired for is just to
reach over grab my phone and just check
few emails absent-minded lead him by the
time I've done that that then normally
means I'm awake enough to actually get
up properly so that's how I beat that
urge just hit snooze I think well I
definitely get up but if I can just prop
myself up and do something I'm looking
forward to - and as soon as I think oh
yeah maybe you know someone's left a
comment on my website and I'm like yeah
I'll check that even though I'm
exhausted you say I mean you need
something that if you can find him that
will motivate you to get just one stage
closer to getting up and then that'll
help you I think helped me to wake up in
the morning note that if you use these
tips and you're finding it's still very
difficult to wake up in the morning
perhaps you're feeling a bit sick a lot
of people feel a bit sick in the morning
perhaps you're feeling weirdly cold but
feel like you've got a cold
sniffle iNOS there's a few things that
can cause that and that you might want
to consider one is that you could be you
could have an allergy even if you don't
know that you've got hay fever or
something you can develop it at any age
and often it's worse in the morning
because you've been asleep all night so
if you've got your window ajar as I
suggested earlier there might actually
be a bad thing if you happen to have an
allergy - dander so try closing it see
if that improves matters
another possibility is mold in your
house you might be having you might be
getting mold poisoning so if you suspect
this could be the case maybe there's a
down smell in your house then look into
that as well because that can leave you
feeling scratchy throat in the morning
another consideration is that you're
just dehydrated this is a problem that
I suffer with so I get a bed with lots
of water and I drink large amounts of
water which makes me believe you know
catch-22 you get it just right another
option is to try using chia seeds these
absorb water if you eat them then in
theory they should release the moisture
more gradually throughout the night I
have initially tried that one but you
could try that one another one is you
might have sleep apnea this means you're
waking up for brief spells during the
night if you think you have sleep apnea
the best thing to do is to ask somebody
to check you what's your sleep probably
a partner or just that creepy guy watch
as you sleep otherwise you could go to
the sleep clinic and have them fill me
you can even film yourself so this means
you're waking up in the night but very
briefly because you can't breathe and
you don't remember it so if you have
that you need to sort it out and maybe
give it in a CPAP machine by the
doctor's continuous positive airway
pressure device finally it could be that
you've got low blood sugar and this is
why some people recommend eating a
spoonful of honey which the effects of
that might be negligible for most people
but if you do suspect that you might
have low blood sugar when you go to
sleep then try that one and it might
help so yeah consider that if you're
feeling rough in the morning it might
mean that something's not right could
also mean that you are just fighting a
cold
in which case give yourself some rest
take some time off of the gym you might
be able trained also stock up on
vitamins and minerals and finally one
last thing that I'd like to go over is
using CBT or cognitive behavioral
therapy to try and help yourself fall
asleep if you're someone who suffers
with a kind of insomnia I'm not talking
clinical insomnia here because I'm not I
don't know enough about that to help you
out but if you just struggle getting
yourself to sleep and calming down in
the evening then what can help is to
change the way you think about sleep and
that's the idea of CBT something I'll be
talking more about in future videos so
in this case if you're trying to force
yourself to get to sleep and if you're
thinking in your heads man I'm so tired
and for every minute that Ghost passed
I'm gonna be tired of tomorrow and you
look at the clock and it's for anything
everyone else is asleep and what you're
actually doing is stressing yourself out
you're producing more adrenaline and
more of dopamine although kind of
excitable neurotransmitters and hormones
and that's making your heart rate get
higher as the opposite of being able to
sleep well so what you need to do
instead is just met
gay as Elsa would say and relax and just
let yourself fall asleep or not you got
to take the pressure off so I used to
struggle with insomnia when I was much
younger because of all the demons my mum
used to say don't worry about getting to
sleep just lie there and relax because
at the very least relaxing is better for
you than nothing which is true so
instead of trying to force myself to
sleep I'll just think oh this is nice so
just like it and I'll think about my
ideas and you know I'll maybe just you
know enjoy being quiet and not having
any stress and as soon as you do that
you fall asleep that's the irony as soon
as you think I'm loving lying here I
could lie here all night and not even
worry about safe that's when you fall
asleep say get a bed not so slowly even
with the intention of getting to sleep
right away let your body worry about
that you just worry about relaxing and
feeling comfortable and yeah if you can
stay awake longer lying there just
enjoying not having to be anywhere or do
anything and let them get to think over
your ideas then that's great and I'm
pretty sure when you do that you'll find
you sink off to sleep pretty quickly so
hope that helped somebody as usual
thanks for watching hope you enjoyed
this one something a little bit
different and I'll be back to usual
training and brain training and
productivity videos as usual in the next
one say thanks again and see you next
time bye for now
bonus round if you find that you aren't
able to get enough sleep then there is a
chance for a reprieve you can have a
power nap at some point during the day
just make sure that when you do this you
sleep between 20 and 90 minutes no wrong
you sleep not between those amounts you
sleep up to 20 minutes or over 90
minutes reason being that sleep cycle is
90 minutes if you go if you wake up
prior to 20 minutes then you wake up
before you reach the deeper stages of
sleep if you wake up after the 90
minutes to wake up after the deeper
stages of sleep at least that's the
theory it's not always that easy because
you can't time exactly how long it takes
you to sleep and of course nothing is
completely clockwork in the body but as
a general rule that's how you want a
power nap and if you do these proper
long power naps for 90 minutes then
studies show that they wake you up and
make you more productive more so than
something like a spot of caffeine so
something to consider